my uncle told I I didn't find out about
this but my uncle told me that it came
to a point where
um
uh my mom my and my two uncles tied
themselves to a barrel because the sea
was like crazy storms right and if they
said if they're gonna die they're gonna
die together
like it was that bad so they they tied
themselves to this barrel and just
risked it in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of The Genius brain podcast we
have a very special guest here as you
guys know with even the last episode I'm
starting to Feature A lot of people who
I really really [__] with
um just because I think I'm known to
talk a lot of [__] which is [__] true
baby let's go
but I'm also a sweet ass [__]
stay with your chest dude yeah so I've
been wanting to really introduce a lot
of people too I mean even if they are
well known right
um with our guest here he's super well
known specifically in The Culinary world
when it comes to like uh Instagram
content on food and just food in general
but
I I'm a big stickler for yeah I'll speak
up about things that I dislike but I
also have to speak about things that I
really do like and people who I feel are
like either the current generation or
the next generation of content creators
and food content has been popping like
none other yes sir um it's like started
with people just going to restaurants
and reviewing them or just you know
showing people the places that they like
to eat but recently in terms of like
Fast content in terms of Instagram
stories and reels recipes have been
[__] huge and I think because of
pandemic everybody was cooking at home
and they had to know how to make the
foods that they enjoy which is something
that I really [__] with because when you
cook food at home you now have a better
understanding of what goes into a a dish
before you go and you start reviewing
and bashing stuff right yes so we have
David doing also known as the [__]
you know
Yeah man so David and I we were just
eating uh just chopping up about food
because we could talk about food all day
every day and um I I actually first came
onto your stuff just through like
Instagram uh reels and stuff and one of
the things that I really did appreciate
about the way that you cooked was that I
could tell we were just talking about
this you actually do r d before you put
the recipe out which in this world of
fast content a lot of like cooking
people now because it's been so popular
people just put out a recipe they don't
know if it's [__] good or not they've
never tried it before and they go this
is how you make it and then when I tried
your recipes out I'm like oh he went
through steps on this because this [__]
is [__] fire I told him I tried his
your etouffee recipe [__] delicious
and I saw other people reposting it too
so I must be like one of your most
popular ones it's it's the hottest one
man yeah man so like for you
I I was actually interested because when
you you actually did a video that I
really really liked which was um you
were just cooking and prepping and you
were talking about uh growing up in
Vietnam in your family's story yeah and
I personally resonate with that a lot
because
I really [__] with how the or like
everybody's origin story yeah right and
food is something that's very personal
to me and I think for a lot of people
and when I went like for example if I
asked you a question like
what would you what what are the meals
that you want to eat before like the day
before you die right and usually it's
the foods that you're either your mom or
your dad cooked or something that's very
personal yeah and most people would
think I think before that question is
ask them it's this fine dining
restaurant here lobster tail steak but
for me it wasn't it's the soybean soup
that my mom made this uh this rice pores
my mom made yeah and you know these are
like the origin stories where I feel a
lot of chefs kind of develop their
palette and their passion for food yeah
so how did that start for you
um
bro like my I mean well hold on let me
time out real quick Jesus Christ that
intro uh how often do you do this uh
once a week
but that was such a great intro
um but going back to origin stories uh
in terms of culinary like my food origin
story or just everything like well let's
let's start off with um the stories that
you were talking about on your Instagram
yeah like the you know especially
because you know a lot of my friends who
are Vietnamese yeah
a lot of refugees yeah you know and that
that origin story to me is always
fascinating yeah
bro like we could go origin story all
day but uh my family uh my mom and dad
met uh in a refugee camp in Palawan
Philippines so after the fall of Saigon
um Everybody fled Vietnam because of all
the uh sanctions you know like it just
wasn't a good place to live for people
and so people fled uh the fortunate
people got to escape by uh
assistance from the military the U.S
militaries and the unfortunate few that
you know didn't have access to that they
fled by boats and fleeing by boats it's
not like oh I'm gonna hop on a boat and
get out of here no it's like secretly
they would have to like have Meetup
points and stuff like oh show up at this
uh at 2 A.M or 3 A.M at this location
and back then when they flee it's like
oh here's a gold bar like that's their
currency like that's how that's their
ticket out here's a gold bar and every
time like and this is like stories from
my mom that she would tell me and my uh
uncle that they told they tried a couple
of times my uncle tried three times my
mom tried twice my dad
um
was the one that uh
that was able to escape on the first try
right because every time you would try
to escape uh you got to do it secretly
in the middle of the night
um otherwise you get yeah right you get
caught by the authorities and you get
sent to jail and all that stuff
um so Mom and Dad Escape they they're
from the same Hometown Escape my mom
went first but they they didn't get
together first my mom went first with
along with two of um her brothers
um was able to go uh their trip their
Journey was like seven days at Seas
seven days and sixth night or whatever
but to them it felt like forever because
you're talking about like uh the South
China Sea so it's like freaking storming
and like the stories that they tell me
man is like it's crazy it's stuff that I
don't think I would be able to live
through because it's
um it's like you're talking about
cannibalism like because you're out at
Sea with no food supply you're on a
small fishing boat with
packed full of people like they
witnessed cannibalism what the [__] yeah
like people had to draw sticks uh when
it came time like they had to draw
straws to like oh like sorry you gotta
like it's man like the whole vibe
changed like we were chopping it up all
adorable but like but that's the reality
of it and it's stuff that not many
people talk about nowadays but um I've
never heard that part yeah right because
I don't think I think when people Regale
the story they always
kind of Breeze over it I think because
it's such a trouble because it's it's
super traumatic yeah so when earlier
when I told you oh like like the stuff
about therapy is like I've seen my
parents live through all this and they
till this day they haven't gotten any
therapy so like why would I you know I
mean like I got a [__] for [__] man
um no but like they Breeze through it
because it's that traumatic yeah you
know it's it's you're talking about
witnessing cannibalism uh people how to
drink their own piss because there's no
water source uh for them at or whatever
they packed it wasn't enough to for them
because they don't they didn't know back
then they didn't know how long
um The Journey was gonna be you know
yeah so it's it's all of that it was I
think my last trip to Vietnam my uncle
told I I didn't find out about this but
my uncle told me that it came to a point
where
um
uh my mom my and my two uncles tied
themselves to a barrel because the sea
was like crazy storms right and if they
said if they're gonna die they're gonna
die together
yeah like it was that bad so they they
tied themselves to this barrel and just
wrist it right and there was another uh
random lady that say hey um hey I have
nobody here like no relatives on this
boat with me can I join you guys like so
they all tied themselves to this Barrel
is [__] nuts yeah so if so the reason
why they uh tied themselves to the
barrel is because when they if if you
know
um they fall over or whatever their
bodies will float together so that news
would if they were found news would be
sent back home to Vietnam like oh hey
we've got a survival tactic exactly it
wasn't like say if you're in the
military you have the dog tags or
whatever right for them it's like oh
like we found all three of your kids
body and that's
that's yeah so but luckily they made it
so and when they made it
it wasn't like oh we're safe or whatever
like they just kind of like landed in
the Philippines if they just so happened
to land in the Philippines so depending
I guess depending on which region in
Vietnam you're from
um your land and in different areas so
for where my parents were from they land
in the Philippines but some people they
they will then in Thailand Cambodia
Malaysia so that's why you see like
Vietnamese like oh like oh I'm
Vietnamese but I know like some Cambodia
yeah like my friend
um
well he's I think he's ethnically
Vietnamese but
he speaks both Chinese and Vietnamese so
it's like it's a lot of that you know
right so yeah it's it's a lot of that so
my my mom made it or my mom and my two
uncles made it to the Philippines
um and then my dad was able to get on
another boat because he was a mechanic
right and back back in the days
mechanics with trips like that you need
somebody who knows how to fix you how to
fix [__] right so he didn't have to pay
a gold bar he just he just had he just
said oh I'm a mechanic you know so like
he was prioritized to be on the boat so
he came after and it wasn't until my dad
came to the camp that my dad and my mom
got together my dad was friends with my
mom's brother which is my uncle so
that's how they kind of met
um that's my origin story and they had
in the Philippines uh dad from my dad
went from being a mechanic
uh to becoming a fisherman
uh with my uncle like they had to learn
how to fish because he didn't he didn't
uh
he he couldn't be a mechanic in in the
refugee camp for some reason so he had
to learn how to fish from the locals and
became one of the most respective or
respected fishermen at the camp that's
crazy yeah because now he's making his
own hooks and [__] yeah yeah yeah he
knows which area and which water like
had the like I still till this day I
have the picture with his biggest catch
um and I'll show you later like his
biggest catch and that picture happened
by accident like someone just happened
to walk by with a camera and snapped
that picture and it was like a fat ass
swordfish which is like [__] crazy so
my dad and my uncles became fishermen
and that's how
um he would provide for the family my
mom
take that fish and soul and process it
and sold fish at the market and that's
like they're entrepreneur and that's how
they were able to were able to provide
for myself and my younger brother in the
refugee camp
um
so I was born in the Philippines
lived there for five years and
eventually the
um United Nation
uh basically said hey this Refugee thing
is getting out of hand too many people
are like escaping coming in we can't
handle it so they were forcing people to
go back home
like hey you gotta go back home
yeah so imagine like imagine it like put
yourself in that situation right like
you just Escape I tied myself to a
[__] Barrel to get here yeah like
right like just go gone through
everything right witnessing all this
crazy stuff to now you have to go back
home
so
my mom my parents and I've asked her
like why did you agree to go back home
because you you could have people had a
choice to stay back
um but my mom was like I didn't I didn't
see a future for you or your younger
brother here in the Philippines
so that's why I was born in the
Philippines Palawan Philippines now it's
a [__] uh tourist destination
beautiful Waters
um but yeah I was born in the
Philippines people are shocked when they
find that I was like how are you uh are
you able to speak tagalogs nah bro I
wasn't for a hot second it's just real
quick yeah
um so I was born in the Philippines
um lived there for five years and then
at the age of five
um we packed up and went back to Vietnam
and a lot of people a lot of people and
when I made that video on Instagram like
uh why did you why did your parents
Escape just to go back to Vietnam right
and I well I didn't dive deep into the
reply or whatever but
um to cut it short it's they didn't have
a choice yeah like they were told by the
government to just pack up you know and
dip
um and well actually they kind of did
have a choice but
um
they they just didn't see a future for
us so we went back to Vietnam uh going
back to Vietnam uh dad went from
fisherman back to a mechanic mom
learned how to cook from one of her
aunties and open up a rice like a street
side Rice Shop and sold a broken rice
okay that's the [__] baby let's go for
everybody at home
um
and
what else yeah so well hold on that's so
[__] crazy dude right
start the story because I like the whole
vibe change really we were just well
like as you're talking I feel like I'm
watching a movie right now because I've
heard a lot of these Refugee stories
right yeah um obviously are my
immigration story is a lot nicer than
yours kind of playing Pop here boom here
I am yeah
um but you know I've had friends who's
mother was like brought here because
literally the story is from what she
told him it's like no I remember my mom
Lifting me up in the air and going into
a GI take my kid to take my kid and
that's just like have you seen Hey
Arnold yeah yeah yeah it was an episode
that portrayed that exactly like that
whole situation exactly and that's just
real and so that's what his mom told
like no my mom was holding on she goes
so his mom
doesn't know if any of her relatives are
alive yeah because the last person that
she saw was her mom asking a GI to take
her and then took her and then she got
adopted into a white family yeah and
that's her whole experience here but you
know while she was in Vietnam I think
she lost her hearing or some [__]
something happened to her there
um
but like these these little
I think like sometimes it's hard for
people to even understand
what people did to even get here right
and it's just sometimes we kind of like
take for granted for what the things
that we have and I talked about this
where uh well well I love these stories
because it always puts it into
perspective of what you have and it also
helps you live life a lot happier yeah
because
you know we see this a lot with a lot of
celebrity kids right where they're
always searching for meaning because
they've been given everything yeah the
whole world is given to them there's no
come up you're at the come-up spot yeah
so they have no perspective yeah so the
only things that they can do is act out
be outlandish for them to be different
in some type of way yeah and I'll even
see this with um a small scale of it
like where I I had this like stand-up
set back and then I used to talk about
like poor people can't even be poor
anymore and the reason what I mean by
that is like when poor people talk about
poor people [__] there's always some
rich [__] being like I know what
you went through it's like Oh shut the
[__] up like I can't even be poured out
like let me let me have my poor woes
yeah now you try to appropriate my poor
culture like the [__] out of here dude
it's like for example like I had um
uh I I know somebody who uh who bought
this really nice house yeah and I know
what they do for a living I know how
much money they make we're like in the
same field and they bought a really
expensive house right it's nobody you
guys [__] know so stop trying to
guess
um but
yeah I we were talking chopping it up
and this person was saying that they
saved up all this money through all the
influencing stuff that they've done to
buy this and I looked at them I was like
you don't make as much money as me yeah
no way but I I you know I'm just going
to always believe what they tell me and
then later on it was like a couple
months later I was talking to another
friend I was like dude man we're talking
about our mutual friend I was like
[__] this person Hustle Hard like
made all that money they bought this
that's crazy and she looked at me she
goes well they didn't I'm like what do
you mean it's like the parents are rich
the parents bought that house for them
what and they had to think about it and
I go wait
why did they tell me that I never asked
but they volunteered this lie to me yeah
like oh what is that about and I didn't
really think about is they don't they
want to be a part of something yeah they
like that struggle story so they want to
be a part of it which is so odd like
yeah perspective wise too everybody
wants a little piece of what you have
even if it's not something desirable
yeah like hearing this story too will
give people a lot of perspective about
where they are in their life yeah
because I I I'm picturing somebody
picking out straws well guess who's
dinner
I didn't like you you're done bro it's
like it's a [__] like I mean we joke
around but it's so [__] that's
[__] I couldn't imagine like imagine
you just like you with your cousin or
whatever and then it was your cousin's
time or he just picked the roster I know
they're gonna eat me first too I'm I'm
beefy dude they're Fair back
they're gonna automatically give me the
shortest
strawberry and then I pick it up it's
like well if we kill him we'll eat for a
very long time we kill David we don't
gotta pick straws for the next three
weeks they're like listen either we kill
this one person or we eat four of us
we'll just kill them
I know everybody's licking their lips
around me he's like I haven't even
picked straws yet
people just like [__] pitching me to
see my fat content it's like oh you got
some wagyu [__] marbling 85 bms7 what
is this how long is it gonna take David
to render I know that'd be spit roasting
his [__] like hey you looking at me
funny dude say we need some baking soda
you know and change out the pH level on
his skin yeah
which works with [__] pork belly
let's go baby oh my God
yeah that story is so [__] nuts to me
man and then so for you uh what age were
you when you came here I was eight years
old oh yeah so
um five years old we went to Vietnam I
went through the whole school system
three years and during that time my my
mom sold rice plates just hustling on
the street to provide for the family and
from that they eventually saved up
enough money to open up a small little
convenience store like a little liquor
store in a hospital
um where they still serve food out of
and at eight years old not not night you
owe at eight years years old for me they
received the news
um
that they were able to be interviewed to
come to America wow right and this was
this was this came as a surprise for
them because they didn't expect it
um so it was basically whoever
volunteered whoever volunteered to go
back from the Philippines because the
United Nations told people to go back
right and whoever obliged
there was a program that opened up for
people that obliged and if you left at a
certain time frame you would qualify
right and they made the move right they
made it go no but it like even so you
had you still had to go through an
interview process yeah so I remember
like
um my family we would go to uh Saigon
um
just for an interview I didn't even know
what it was about mom just told say just
say yes no or whatever and this was like
of course broken down like you know like
I didn't know like English I was eight
years old so we had we went through a
whole interview process and I think that
interview process was just basically to
see if you know you would
be okay in society over here you know
like you wouldn't be like
um I don't know like a menace or
whatever yeah yeah yeah yeah obstruction
or whatever
um so yeah like our family we passed our
interview luckily
um and I remember just the last memory
when I was eight years old uh riding in
a sit low you ever seen a sit low yeah
yeah right from my aunt's house honestly
low to the airport and that was my last
memory of like Vietnam Descent of like
durian and like just you know like
street food smell of Vietnam and that
was like the last scent or whatever so
at eight years old we came here because
to Southern California because my mom
had an aunt that lived in Southern
California her husband served in the
military so they were able to come here
first
um
so we ended up in La Habra California
stay there for a little bit like couple
months just to like uh
situate ourselves I guess and then
eventually my family got a two bed two
bath apartment in Anaheim California
uh with the help from government like
food stamps and all that assistance like
housing and all that stuff and that's
that's where we or that's where I grew
up
um Dad went from being a mechanic to now
had to learn construction because most
of the people so we they had friends who
were from the refugee camp that landed
in SoCal as well so they were like
talking to each other like back in the
days they fished together right back in
uh the Philippines they would fish
together but now they're in a whole new
country oh what are we doing to make
money yeah construction because no
English was required right and they
would work under somebody who knows
English that could bring in the deal or
it would be in a Vietnamese Community
where they could communicate in
Vietnamese so they'll be able to you
know fix stuff for so I guess he's like
a general contractor or like a handyman
or whatever so that's what my dad did
and I give him mad props because this
guy [__] went from mechanic
fishermen like he adapted and thrived to
now a handyman that's [__]
I think I would have died instantly they
gave me that golden ticket I would have
been on that boat and they're like
where'd David go I think he fell off
he's been 10 minutes no he was dead
chewing on my legs
we got the side dishes right yeah what
the [__] y'all got [__] like little
[__] Nook bomb [__]
[__] y'all doing dude get the [__] away
from me oh man yeah yeah so uh dad dad
became a handyman mom from uh selling
street food to running a convenience
store to now uh doing nails
she went to nail school because that's
what majority of the people did or like
basically like word from the community
right to ship all the way through right
yeah because uh not a lot of English was
required and you're working on
Vietnamese community so it's easy
um so yeah that's basically my story or
my origin story I would say and bro like
just
growing growing up in like not knowing a
word like for me like I started third
grade when I came here yeah that's why I
wanted to ask you like yeah adaptation
must have been really [__] difficult
it was [__] tough dude did you get
bullied a lot I still need therapy did
you get bullied a lot uh yeah I was I
would say I think my first experience
with racism was my first day of school
damn man yeah uh and man back kids back
then they're [__] they're me bro oh
it's a different breeding the teachers
wouldn't help you out you know like it
would be the first day and back then
it's like you gotta walk to the bus stop
buses didn't come to your house and pick
you up you gotta walk to the bus stop
right and you know and the first
experience like I remember so vividly it
was just uh some Hispanic kids my like
around my age were like ching chong like
I didn't I didn't understand it but I
knew they were trying to like you know
make fun of you yeah exactly so that was
my first experience um
I wouldn't say I was bullied a lot but
um it's tough yeah it's tough to
navigate I mean imagine anybody else
like I see foreigners go into some place
like Japan which is like one of the most
hospitable places on Earth yeah and they
can't even navigate there yeah imagine
you know moving to a foreign country
where everything's spread apart there's
no really good public transportation and
on top of that too it's like the
acceptable thing to make fun of you all
the [__] time yeah I think because uh
I think Sacramento is so hyper diverse
those a lot of people just couldn't
speak English yeah you know so we were
like the majority yeah and the tough
part about that is like or maybe
when I was telling you like the
generation before us specifically a lot
of like Vietnamese refugees and you know
people from like China or a lot of these
Asian people they don't understand like
the origin of like Asian gangs yes
because [__] would bully these
guys yeah and they come from very very
tough upbrings yeah like you know you
want to talk about it's like oh I'll
beat your ass like [__] I hate
my cousin like I I had him for lunch
before I came here
think about you and so a lot of these
gangs happen because of the way that
they were treated here and the only way
that they would get people to lead them
alone is that they made them scared of
them so and I'll tell you
I could have went down that path could
have but yeah a lot of people went down
that [__] path man yeah
that's why I'm always curious because
you came here you know so late yeah uh
in your life because I came here when I
was two yeah so my experience is a
little different so by the time I hit
kindergarten I could already speak a
little league yes but my brother uh he
came here when he was five and he used
to get frustrated and mad in class
because he couldn't speak English yeah
and it was just it was really hard for
him growing up yeah you know you got you
get made fun of you get picked on which
I never got to experience uh luckily
because by the time I it was five I was
already fine yeah and I think that's the
same experience that my younger brother
had because he by the time he hit School
he was already able to you know go
through the process of like kindergarten
and all that stuff and learn English and
bro it was it was a struggle I'll tell
you that like yeah a lot of I think what
helped was a lot of uh Saturday cartoons
yeah yeah yeah a lot of PBS dude PBS
taught me how to speak English too PBS
was the [__] back yes PBS and I don't
know like all the PBS like after school
shows like resume or like Reading
Rainbow or like rainbow painting with uh
with Bob Bob Ross yeah Bob Ross oh my
God that was a lot of you know public
television is pretty amazing so I'm not
sure if anybody saw this but if you saw
the Mr Rogers documentary was pretty
amazing when Mr Rogers passed away it's
the weirdest thing happened I remember
the exact moment he died I was driving
my car and mind you I haven't seen Mr
Rogers Neighborhood since I was a little
kid yeah but you know I watched him very
very frequently number one too broke to
have cable so it was only public
television yeah
um we were watching that and then
um
LeVar Burton from Reading Rainbow Sesame
Street all this stuff is you know
basically my me acclimating to American
culture and learning how to speak the
language yes through these shows
I was in the car and I heard on the
radio that Mr Rogers died and I was like
oh that's sad and I started [__]
tearing up yeah and I didn't know why
I'm being part of your child she was
like you watched him all the time when
you were a kid so he was kind of a huge
part of who raised me yeah so you know
like public television when we were a
kid was amazing and if you guys ever get
to watch that documentary you'll see
that doc where there's Mr Rogers he's
basically pleading to keep public
television alive yeah dude that was like
one of the most powerful things that I
saw yeah and I think that's the stuff
that I I you know enjoyed about uh my Me
growing up here as a foreign kid yeah
was that our experiences in terms of who
Our Heroes were were really wholesome
people like that uh when I watch him as
adult I'm like then she's boring as [__]
it's like two different Vibes but as a
kid it was it was [__] amazing yeah
and he would talk about personal values
about loving yourself appreciating what
you have and who you are yeah which I
think really did affect my mentality as
adult today yeah I don't know but these
are like the small seeds that get
planted in you oh for sure like
subliminal seeds oh for sure yeah 100 so
like when I when I look back at some of
the content I'm like oh it's crazy how
the stuff that he's talking about in
these videos is stuff that I talk about
as an adult yeah and I just never
realized that I probably learned it from
him yeah
yeah so like
when I when I when I see like people's
stories like yours it's pretty insane
like especially from an immigrant
perspective it's so hard to acclimate
into this country yeah and they kind of
feel like
um like you're not an outsider yeah uh I
think this year specif or not this year
but the last two three years
uh has been really transforming and how
people view their identity as an
American yeah because prior to all this
stuff too and maybe not
for a lot of people for the younger
generation anyways the identity of being
an American nobody really thought about
what it is to be an American right
because I think that you know when you
go to a lot of other countries because
they are a lot smaller and how they
started and their history is a lot
deeper than America yeah
um people have a certain sense of
nationality and Oneness so if you go to
Korea people generally have the same
idea of what it is to be a Korean person
they're all there's obviously I'm not
speaking in general in generalities like
what everybody thinks like this but when
they say Korean Pride people have a
general sense of what that is yeah um in
Japan they have that too over here when
they ask you what it is to be an
American
[__] I don't know you know it's it's
yeah so when somebody looks at you know
you or me maybe if they're not in
California they go They're not American
but who who what what definition is it
they go that's the most Un-American
thing what is it to be an American yeah
your definition is going to be different
from mine yeah and so we we really got
to experience that and I think like for
me
um when I see
people
kind of forget where they come from it
makes me a little sad yeah uh because
sometimes people believe that their
identity as an American person is to
forget what made them who they are no so
they go oh I'm American now like I don't
you don't need to learn how to speak
Vietnamese you don't need to learn how
to speak Korean like you're not going to
need that and I think it runs deeper
than that I I hope that's not the case
because a lot of people think that way
though where they I think they
they think that their culture is based
basically just the food and that's where
it ends yeah and I think from an outside
perspective that's a great way to start
but when you are like for me as a Korean
person
I couldn't really speak Korean
um only up until like the last six or
seven years yeah and it was pretty damn
bad yeah
um because I never spoke it and because
you you know grew up here exactly but
then my wife she speaks Korean fluently
yeah and what I realized years ago was
the biggest reason why I couldn't get
along with my parents was because I
couldn't understand them I couldn't
speak the [__] language
so it's kind of a spiteful way to do
things but I was like I'm gonna learn
the language so I could tell them to go
[__] off
[Laughter]
at least you got your motivation yeah so
I'm over here Anime styled you know all
the [__] the Montage scene I'm
learning how to speak Korean but what
actually turned out what happened was I
actually got to understand them better
yeah where because we got into these
arguments and I could speak not
completely fluently but to the point
where we could actually have an argument
yeah and I can understand what they're
saying I got to know them better yeah
and I got to know myself better you guys
are still arguing to this day no not
really not geez I mean we argue because
that's just how we talk yeah I mean how
I talk is how my mom talks so I learned
how to speak for my mom like my mom
literally has told me to kill myself
multiple times like that's just how
Korean people are there's a very famous
saying it goes
that literally every Korean kid has
heard of this phrase and that literally
means I'll kill you I'll kill myself
I'll kill everybody
foreign
[Laughter]
stop calling me a [__] she goes that's
just how Korean people do it I was like
I don't think so I think it's you I was
like don't call your kids [__] she's
like Hey Oh after how many years now you
finally know what restarted I've been
calling you a [__] for like 30 years
now you have a problem
oh man but anyways like how did you um
going back to the food thing like
how did you start going into oh why did
you decide to become a chef
um so going back to learning English or
PBS like you know a lot of cooking shows
on PBS and growing up around that I
think that influenced me a little bit
just like continue to watch like cooking
shows like uh Ming Tsai or like that
you can't cook [__] me inside Julia
Child Jack Pitt yeah
but also I think I got into cooking uh
mainly from my mom
amazing cook right even though she does
Nails uh till this day she'll tell me
that if she did not had to hustle to
provide for the family or help my dad
hustle to provide for our family will
probably be in the restaurant business
right now instead of the nail game right
like amazing cook
um so my mom influenced me I grew up
watching her from hustling you know uh
with her street side set up a selling
gumtum or at family gatherings you know
like should be in the kitchen or
whenever there's a a moment you're like
oh hey make the sauce make make the fish
sauce make the new champ blah blah right
and it'll just be me on the floor
squatting Asian flop squatches
uh on the mortar and pestle I think just
like those small moments like that
um influenced me in uh in my decision to
pursue cooking later on as a career
would you say that so your mom is like
your biggest influence oh she was the OG
influence
yeah that's like the first dish that you
ever made the first dish that I ever
made was uh balupla which is a shaking
beef that is the [__] right there baby
let's go and because to impress a girl
obviously I mean I think this is like
back in like AOL aim days or whatever
like we're just I was talking to a girl
and for some reason like and I don't
know why I remember this so much it's
like she was like do you know what I
could I was like yeah I know how to cook
you know it's like but I was BS and of
course oh yeah yeah I knew it was like
mortar and mess over like I didn't know
how to make anything yet
um so the first dish that I learned how
to make was uh yeah that's to impress
this girl uh she where she we're not in
contact anymore of course but
um but my shaking beef game has improved
since so
um yeah that was one of the first dishes
that I learned how to cook and it was
until after high school that I decided
to pursue culinary as a profession
um my first job out of uh
high school was at was as a barista at
taste tea oh really yeah first job and
the only job that I got fired from for
reals what'd you get fired for for not
remembering recipes
the [__] coincidence wow that's
hilarious what kind of recipe game yeah
yeah right so like so we're taking the
400 drinks yeah right so what tasty is
like they have so many drinks and
there's always qcqcqc right and this was
like in the early stages of their
opening so you would figure like how how
much they're they're beyond their people
like major quizzes every time so I
struggle with that
so second job after tasty was at Lee
sandwich
um Brookhurst and Westminster location
okay 24-hour only 24 hour Lee sandwich
location I worked there for two years
graveyard shifts
um overnight graveyard shifts so the
thing with graveyard shows is that yo
get to meet everybody right and so if
you guys don't know Lee Sandwiches like
the the McDonald's version of bug me
yeah for those who don't know yeah it's
like in every corner it was like the
introduction for a lot of people's uh it
was an introduction for bug me for a lot
of people yeah yeah so
and and I'll get to the your answer but
so with working graveyard shift at least
sandwich you know I get to meet
everybody and most of the people who
would come in our restaurant Cooks
because it's like 2 A.M or whatever and
they'll come in grab their baguette or
buy me because they just got out of work
late or whatever so I see these people
come in with their chef code so I'm like
damn they look official like that's a
whole Chef I'm over here with like a
polo and Lee sandwich [__] like like so
I would ask these people like I I
already knew I can somewhat cook but I
just didn't know that I could do it as a
profession type of thing right so I
would ask these people like hey like
what's the process of uh becoming a chef
right and people's like oh go just go to
culinary school you know uh go to go to
culinary school do this that whatever
like Okay cool so I signed up for
culinary school what where did you go I
went to the Art Institute in Costa Mesa
okay it's closed now but
um but yeah culinary school that's like
a whole different thing but the ones in
La now it's like the new age of cooking
is one that popped up after the Cordon
Bleu went down yeah
um they took over a lot of the cordon
blue spots yeah I think it's like ice or
whatever I'm not sure if that that's
like the New York location but uh so our
Institute also closed down because of a
whole thing that you know they they got
caught up on little Scandal Scandal yeah
um so yeah I I applied for culinary
school
um just I just signed up for a two-year
degree but I did not complete culinary
school because during culinary school I
also
um signed up to go work at different
restaurants just to get uh experience uh
one of the first restaurants that I
worked at
um or applied for I didn't have any
experience so I just Googled up best
Vietnamese restaurant in OC right uh
some fine dining concept came up so I
just went and knocked on the door hey
I'm a culinary student
um I would love to work for you but I
don't have any experience can I apply to
be your dishwasher right I just want I
just want to get in the door
um
so that's how I got in with my first
restaurant job but they were like oh no
uh you're not gonna wash dishes you're
gonna serve table because we need
servers right now uh so that was one of
my first kitchen jobs while I was in
culinary school and
from that kitchen job
uh they were like oh no
um
I don't have because they're they're
operating a restaurant but also a bakery
as well it's like oh I don't have enough
time to Mentor you
I'm gonna introduce you to uh this place
called ESPN so like I know somebody that
could get you into ESPN Zone which is
owned by Disney in Downtown Disney
um
and that's how I was able to get my next
job into ESPN Zone and and this is all
happening while I'm in culinary school
right
um and from ESPN Zone
one random day
and I've been at ESPN Zone for like a
year year and a half now one random day
my sous chef was like hey uh Disney is
uh hiring for their concept called Club
33 you should apply
I was like what's Club 33 yeah yeah
right went home looked it up it's like
[__] the Illuminati of Disneyland yeah I
was like damn like it was like fancy
food like crazy like I'm not there I'm
still in culinary school at the time
like so I'm like damn I'm not good
enough so I was like a lot of self-talk
I was gonna talk myself out of it but I
was like you know what [__] it take
until you make it baby let's go
maybe fake it but I was like I said [__]
it I applied I got their interview
right and their their interview process
is like I went through five interviews
David damn for a kitchen job a cook job
right but then again it's a cook job
with no with little to no uh restaurant
experience and while I'm still in
culinary school at this like really
Prestige at that level would be like
prestigious for Disneyland so I got
accepted I went through a personality
interview or like
um and I just remember the last
interview was a mystery basket
really yeah like have you seen chop I'm
sure you've seen yeah 100 yeah so which
is kind of crazy yeah so yeah I mean I
say mystery basket but really is uh
mystery Pantry Yeah so basically you
come in for the interview you bring your
knife set or whatever
they're like okay you have three hours
to put together three dishes a appetizer
uh Maine and dessert God damn to serve a
panel of five judges I was like oh three
hours for one dish not bad no that's
like so three dishes meal three dishes
yeah
um
and once again I'm still in culinary
you're like my very first girlfriend
oh my God my appetizer was
um so in the walk-in they had halibut
right so you don't know what the heck
you're getting you you're just walking
in whole Pantry full of stuff uh halibut
cool what what can I do with halibut
okay I see rice paper Okay boom uh
Vietnamese let me make [__] spring
rolls so for appetizers we did a um
halibut or I did a halibut spring roll
um with the little uh nuk Chum dipping
sauce uh for Maine
shaking beef again of course let's go
shaking beef with uh rice and a little
side salad
um and dessert I did uh cream puffs and
that [__] was a [__] if you if you've
ever made cream puffs anybody make cream
puffs at home you it's people had a
mixer I didn't have a mixer
also you had to do everything manually
Jesus Christ dude like I'll tell you bro
like just stressing like [__] is this
gonna come out right it's gonna puff
yeah yeah but luckily it came out
um time went ran out
served everything and the reviews were
and this is like a panel of five judges
the reviews were uh the appetizer the
fish was overcooked it was dry like uh
the chef couldn't swallow the fish or
whatever and he's not very impressed
because the Nook Chapman sauces wasn't
from scratch it came out of bottles that
I just mixed with sugar and what I liked
and whatever do you want me to go
ferment the [__] fish myself [__] do
you know how hard it is to [__] do
that stuff yeah right let me go fish
this tiny little obscure fish from
Vietnam that they ferment for like a
[__] year and then what the hell are
you talking about no but
um yeah so he goes yeah like I'm not I'm
not that impressed because the sauce
wasn't made from scratch your fish was
overcooked like okay well I didn't say
anything at the time and then moving on
to the main or the main course entree
shaking beefs like um and the plate up
was shaking beat like very basic plated
by the way like you have uh shaking beef
uh rice that I
um shaped in a little pyramid shaper
thing and just dopped it on and just
like a little pile salad a very casual
plate up so the feedback was if I was
coming over to your house for a dinner
party I would be blown away by this but
cooking at the level that we cook here
at Club 33 this is not what we want is
not what we're looking for like damn
sure all right so I mean I wasn't saying
anything back you know I was like okay
thank you Chef you know like so it
tasted good yeah right that means it
tasted good yeah and then
um moving on to the cream puff they're
like you did this by hand I was like
yeah Chef I there was there wasn't a
mixer you know and the cream puff was
plated with uh some fruits and like uh
filled with
um
forgot what was the cream but a pastry
cream yeah yeah it was filled with
pastry cream which also made from
scratch he's a [__] yeah pastry cream
cheese uh so yeah like those were the
reviews they were impressed by the cream
puffs obviously
um and I I thought I did bad but I think
um because based from the first review
second review of the entree I was like
I'm not getting this job yeah you know I
mean like I'm I'm going home I'm not
getting the job so at the end of you I
basically just thank them you know like
hey thank you so much for this
experience regardless if I get the job
or not
I'm thankful because I've learned so
much from this because up until now I
have not done a mystery basket before
um and that's like a legit mystery back
so if people don't know I've you know
I've been a judge on a food show
um yeah contestants do get mystery
baskets on the show but they're
debriefed with what it possibly possibly
could yeah so they have an idea of what
to make exactly so they'll be like okay
you know most likely you're probably
gonna be working with this protein and
this protein and we're thinking about
maybe this theme so just think about
something like that and it'll land on
the mark somewhere and then there's also
a culinary team that helps them along
them yeah you just legit like chop yeah
here you go you know so you have these
ingredients to work with make something
out it's been like where's the tortilla
making a burrito out of everything
um so yeah like uh at the end of the
interview I just thanked them for the
experience and just dip you know didn't
think much of it didn't I didn't think
that I was gonna get the job but a
couple days later I got the phone call
and that was probably my biggest one of
my biggest uh culinary Milestones was
getting Landing the job at Club 33 what
was it like working for them [__] man it
was intense I loved it was intense I
loved every moment of it and
I'll say this on for the record that
there were times where like
I've cried yeah so dude this is what I'm
curious about right yeah have you did
you see the bear I have not only because
I know is triggering because I like I
would love to see it because I've heard
that it's the most accurate um the bear
watching every episode my balls were
tight because yeah the anxiety yeah
right which it's probably one of my
favorite series that I've ever seen in
my life yeah
um from somebody who hasn't worked in
the kitchen and for me to feel like I
have yeah where my heart was like
beating fast out of my [__] chest and
when I watched it I thought the bear was
a movie so when the first episode ended
I was like that's a really good short
film yeah it does an episodic I was like
[__] oh like I don't know if I can
handle this [__] it's like a [__]
roller coaster ride yeah but I've talked
to a few Chef friends and they're like
that [__] was my life yeah like you know
when you're so hyper passionate about
something yeah everything just starts to
eat away at you and the super it's like
balancing your ego balancing the kitchen
staff wanting this failing business to
thrive and then you have your own
personal issues that you're dealing with
and just watching that show that's why I
always wonder what it's like in the
kitchen I mentioned to you that I wanted
to open a restaurant and and then my
friend allowed me to just you know
Shadow him a little bit for somebody who
owns his own place and I was like nope
I'm not doing this yeah I I cannot do
this especially for somebody
when I watch shows like kitchen
nightmare right yeah and you see these
people who walked in and they opened up
a spot that's 6 000 square feet could
seat about 200 people yeah and they go
what is your restaurant experience none
what the [__] were you thinking they
just opened it because
they were passionate they were they kind
of romanticized what it was to be a
restaurant owner to be a chef and the
sad thing is like with Kitchen
Nightmares you could tell these people
cannot cook yeah and they just enjoyed
the lifestyle that they thought what it
would be to be they just like the the
glamor and the you know they just love
to host their friends or whatever but
inventory alone stresses me out yeah
inventory stressed me out dude yeah it's
like okay well we gotta pretty much
guesstimate how many people might be
coming in if not we don't want too much
excess if not I just threw away a [__]
ton of money yeah right oh wait now we
didn't order enough now people are
pissed at me yeah so now we have to make
an adjustment on the fly now we have to
cop meals I'm like okay I can't I can't
it's along with this dude yeah
you're running a ship you're literally
running a [__] ship as head chef you
are [__] running the ship and I can't
I'm getting I'm talking about I'm
getting anxiety dude you're telling me
I don't know how you do it like oh how
you did it that's so insane to me
um no like for somebody who watched the
bear and still get anxiety and you know
not being in the industry imagine for
somebody who has been in that culture
and you know so that's why I try not to
watch it because it just those
flashbacks but
but yeah freaking Club 33 was a crazy
experience I'm always thankful for it
um I learned a lot and
I was in culinary school still right so
here I am in culinary school but also
working at Club 33 right
and at the time like wait a minute why
am I paying so much for school
when I'm learning way more than I am in
school right so I think I had like two
classes left I would have owed an extra
ten thousand dollars or something if I
were to go through with those classes
um so I decided you know what no I'm not
going to continue culinary school I'm
gonna drop out just bet on myself and
just learn and soak in everything at
work and that's what I did
um
yeah so I dropped out of culinary school
uh just do you feel that that's better
oh for sure well if
see the thing is back in back in the
days my mentality was oh in order for me
to be successful in this field I would
have to go to a notable school like a
school with a name you know I mean
um today like for example like kids
would go to CIA like culinary arts of
America uh Culinary Institute of America
yeah so that's like a notable school
right I didn't know that back in the
days but if I did I probably couldn't
afford it
um but yeah I thought I had to you know
go to a notable school to like make it
in this field but now that I'm in now
that I'm here today is like no you just
you don't even need school I I I it's
cool that you brought it up because I
wondered about that yeah only because
you know going to Japan so many times
and talking to people who live there
it's like we do everything by
apprenticeship yeah so you know and I
first got a taste of it when I saw Jiro
Dreams of Sushi yeah and that was
actually a documentary when I first saw
it first of all cinematically was
amazing yeah I was like one of the first
of his kind that would do documentaries
in a cinematic tone and they were
shooting in 24 frames per second it was
pretty amazing beautiful shot on canons
I um I was like okay they had this guy
making [__] eggs for 15 years yeah he
wasn't allowed to touch
anything else yeah and just watching
that and it was oh they don't go to
culinary school you come in you
Apprentice you wash dishes yeah and then
we'll move you up to I don't know
chopping vegetables you know as a prep
cook line cook and even to get a spot as
an apprentice in those sushi restaurant
was pretty damn intense like I I would
hear stories of like oh like they do the
hot towel test yeah yeah like like how
how much do you want to work here yeah
hang on well Japanese people are pretty
[__] nuts about stuff like that you
know uh and I he that guy that who made
the the tamagoyaki he did that and then
he went to Seattle and opened up his own
place super super famous I think he's
gonna open up a spot out here oh for
reals that's what I've heard yeah we're
gonna go there because we gotta try it
out
I want to I want to try that no no no no
after we eat the banseo place
determine
where our friendship you know
I was gonna test my [__] Vietnamese
food palette dude I I listen I I know my
way around the [__] block all right
we'll go we'll go there we'll go to
Saigon Bakery had the lady yell at us
yeah yeah
um so how'd you get into doing uh online
food content oh man there's like there's
more to the journey like before it ends
up in the food content um
so
uh prior to getting like during the
interview for Club 33 I had mentioned to
them that uh I after culinary school I
want to leave to go to Vietnam to study
Vietnamese or yeah Vietnamese cuisine
right that's so hardcore dude yeah well
as as a young cook and after reading all
these uh like culinary materials like as
a young cook you're supposed to like
travel to places and work in different
kitchen and expose yourself to different
kitchen cultures that's how you improve
right so as a young cook uh and in the
in the field we'd say green somebody
who's very green as somebody who's very
green like you have a certain way of
thinking right like very like ego minded
or whatever
um so yeah I told them that I was that I
want to leave to go to Vietnam during
the time of me staying at Club 33 they
try to change my mind you know like we
went through all of this trained you for
like a year or two we you you know like
have you thought about you know not
going to Vietnam it's like no I'm going
to be enough yeah so there was a there
was a chef named Michelle Roo who's
super legendary uh have you heard of The
Rue Brothers no have you heard of aru
yes so they were they invented the route
oh for reals alberu and uh Michelle Roo
okay yeah
um so the Roo Brothers Michelle Bru uh
opened up a restaurant in Danang called
La Maison
1888 yeah
fancy for that area in the
Intercontinental
uh super super great establishment
um so this was back in like 2014 2015.
uh turn turn in my resignation for Club
super cushy job like I I wouldn't regret
I don't want to say I regret it but
looking back I'm like damn like people
like would break an arm and a leg just
to work here like there are people who
are still there that are gonna retire
there right yeah like people love this
place and here I am just throwing it all
away and just you know
um so that's what I did in 2014 I
resigned and packed up my bags to go
work for Michelle Roo in Danang how did
you get that I just applied let's go
without without doing much research just
shot up an email right but when I went
to the name
Michelle and his team already left oh so
it was or it was one of those concepts
of like I'm gonna open up a place slap
my name on it and dip right so
I did my research but not enough
research yeah so here I am leaving my
cushy job at Disneyland moving my life
to Vietnam like and it was like telling
friends and family like they threw a
going away party or like it's like it
was a big deal right went to Vietnam
this thing happened like [__] yeah what
now I'm here yeah right what now right
and during this time I think I told you
earlier um my parents uh moved from
Orange County from Anaheim to Reno
Nevada uh mom moved first dad eventually
moved after because they didn't want to
be away from each other
um so that happened and then I was like
[__] I thought I was gonna be here like
for in Vietnam for like three years yeah
but it turned out to be like three
months because the team pulled out what
am I gonna do now um
little to no money in my pocket so I
can't really like stay and like you know
go work in Vietnamese kitchens or
whatever and if it if I did it'd just be
a total different experience because the
culture is just so different so
I just
threw in the towel when move home
not not even whole move went back to the
States
um
move in with my parents in their one bed
one bath apartment in Reno Nevada
um and just
was lost for a couple of months I was
like wow what the heck was that I think
that was my first major L that I took
right because like here I am like uh I
think my first major career L I think
yeah yeah um Growing Pains yeah right
it's like [__] what was that you know
like and then I was like nah I'm gonna
try it again
so and being and here I am still a young
Cook's mentality right because with the
young Cooks mentality is like oh in
order to be the best you have to work
for the best and what is the best the
best is uh three Michelin star
restaurant
um
so that's what I did I applied
for testostage in kitchen is uh
internship testaj which is like to work
for free
um at bennu oh yes have you heard of
yeah right so for for everybody at home
who uh don't know about bennu bennu is
the first Korean American restaurant to
earn three Michelin stars which is the
most stars that you can
um earn for a restaurant establishment
it was a it's a big deal it was a pretty
[__] big deal it's a huge deal yeah
right so my reasoning is like oh he's
Asian American so he'll you know
somebody I could relate to so I'm gonna
go work for him right and to be able to
get a stage at a three Michelin star
restaurant is almost
impossible I mean yeah it's impossible
because you're working through a stack
of like resumes like people yeah people
are like just throwing in their resumes
and here I am just competing with people
who are from Korea and stuff like it's
not you're not competing with people who
are local in the states it's people from
abroad and [__] right so I went and
applied for bennu for estaj and I got it
damn
yeah
um I mean you keep striking gold though
you would think I mean yes like but
there are still more to this you know
like there's more to the journey right
um so I got the stage and usually stages
are uh three months
like you would in like intern for them
for three months but here I am with a
one month Dodge and when you stash for
somewhere you kind of go in or for me at
least I went in with the mentality of
I'm gonna earn a like I'm gonna earn a
job yeah like I'm I'm gonna bust my ass
off and I'm gonna make sure that I'm
gonna earn like regardless if it's a
dishwashing job or whatever I'm gonna
earn a position at venue right so that's
what I did
um
very little money uh stage day was
coming up uh still haven't made my
living Arrangement or anything so I just
went on Craigslist and went with almost
I think the first ad that I saw of like
900 to share like a six by six rooms
it was actually I'm actually renting out
this little bed
um
from this guy and I had to because I had
no other options right so that's what I
did didn't like interview him or like
get to know him or whatever I just say
hey like I have this thing coming up
like I would love to rent out your space
that's what I did went to San Fran
um
day one estaj got it out the way uh
kicked my butt went home had a
misunderstanding with the guy I'm
staying at but it wasn't a really
misunderstanding now like later that I
found out like he scammed me of 600 oh
[__] not not 600 but of the living like
he would do that just to scam people out
he'll get people in and then make the
situation like difficult for them to
stay with him so that they'll just you
know he'll just take away with the
deposit money
so that's what happened
um
I got I lost so I got into a
misunderstand with him and then I
removed myself from the situation and
that night David I slept in the street
of Chinatown that is crazy in the middle
of January
that's crazy [__] freezing cold and
then you called your parents to like I
ate somebody shut up I don't care they
just hang up the phone that's that's
literally what happened [__] 4am I
kid you not I called my dad because I
didn't have money
I didn't have enough money for a um
Motel just I was bro like during that
time I was rationing a five dollar foot
long for breakfast and dinner that's
crazy dog yeah so like the the things
that you know young Cooks like it's not
just me like there's other Cooks who
like make huge sacrifice for culinary
you know like just to pursue their
passion their dream or whatever right so
four in the Morning phone phone call my
dad bro like again like defeated
hey can you come pick me up like it
didn't work out you know so my dad and
along with my sister they drove through
the snow Reno to San Francisco
um four hours they got there in the
morning picked me up
um man and I the only thing that kept me
warm throughout the night at the park
was a ventilator from
a laundry machine but like a laundry
desk right I was in my sweater
bro they picked me up went to bennu
because I had I had a shift the next day
right I went to bennu [__] went to
the chef my I I couldn't hold back tears
bro like I was like [__] like
Chef I'm so sorry I can't complete this
dodge my uh living Arrangement just fell
through you know like it didn't work out
bawling my eyes out and
um Chef's like it's okay just uh come
back when you figure it out yeah right
so that's that was another L after
Vietnam yeah yeah same year or two I
think uh another l
and then just went back home and then my
mom was like Hey this there's there's
like a pattern going on you know like it
doesn't look like
culinary is you know is your thing yeah
you know
why don't you do nails
you know like just go again don't say
that
mom don't say that dude don't say that
that's exactly what she said she's like
why don't you get a nail license and
just like you you don't have to you know
fully do nails just get a nail license
just in case and do in the meantime
that's why you try to figure it out so
I'm like all right [__] it you know like
here I am just two L's back to back so I
I listened to her and got a nail license
right
um helped out at um our families not not
our our nail salon yet but a family uh
members nail salon for a little bit and
then I was like I I think I did that for
like a couple months
and then I was like I can't do this [__]
bro like this is not for me like there's
still that ego of like a cook like I'm
I'm into culinary I'm chasing something
well you're passionate about it you know
I mean yeah just like which is honestly
90 of the battle for most people yeah
like finding something that you could
really
sacrifice everything for like something
finding something to care about like
that is actually very very difficult
yeah and for most people
um
that I've talked to and I speak about
now which is why you have all these
motivational speakers like garyvee
because he's not essentially trying to
tell you what to do with your life he's
just trying to help you find what makes
you tick yeah and for you it was cooking
to get that up is is literally giving up
your life yeah and that is a very hard
pill to swallow yeah like where all the
signs tell you you should stop this this
is not for you this is not but you know
I need this like this is who I am like I
have to [__] do this it was rough it
was it was so rough yeah so I did I did
nails for like a good couple of months I
was like [__]
I can't do this so I was like okay who
did Corey Lee study under
or at least study under uh Thomas Keller
for eight to ten years right at the
French Laundry let's go baby yeah I was
like all right people who are listening
Thomas Keller is a big [__] deal yeah
he's like the Godfather of uh The
Culinary one right it's like so he did
like who did Corey study under TK okay
I'm gonna go to the source skip skip
Corey like I I don't need relatability
anymore I'm gonna go to the source I'm
gonna go apply for the French Laundry
David I [__] drove four hours from
Reno
to Yountville uh California which is
like in the Napa Valley area
to turn in a resume just to turn in a
resume like I put together a resident
like this really nice like resume with
like their uh uh logo on the front of
the [__] resume really presentable
right when to turn it in
and remember when I said it's almost
impossible to get a stage
that's crazy well so I wonder what the
[__] it is about too or they're just
like all right we'll give this kid a
chance no I think with with with the
thing with the restaurant industry is
like
if you're determined if they could read
that determination from you if they can
read desire from you yeah they'll give
you a chance yeah because the turn the
turnover rate in the restaurant industry
is just so high that
they don't want somebody that's going to
come in and then like leave three weeks
later oh I like to cook yeah right out
of here dude yeah we want people who are
dead like who wants to be here because
they love or they you know want to learn
and grow type of thing so yeah I got the
stage but instead of one month I got a
one day stash okay yeah and this was
during their kitchen remodeling
um [__] I'll take it let's go all right
so they they had a makeshift kitchen out
of uh four shipping containers
[Music]
um yeah so
I got I got the one day Stars went there
the night before because I didn't want
to be late or whatever slept in the car
um just so that I you know I could show
up on time
uh went through the hostage
great experience uh Thomas Keller fed me
uh I remember it so vividly right during
service and everything I was working
next to uh a fish cook named Christina
and during the middle of service uh TK
went came over with a plate of
anyelodi's and like I got this man like
taste this
there
like
that's one of the best like Memories
ever that's crazy dude yeah so it's like
Michael Jordan giving you a basketball
and being like hey shoot this
[Laughter]
yeah so that happened and um towards the
end of service uh the shafted Cuisine
his name is uh David Breeden
um he asked me when do I want to come
back and my reply was
whenever you want me to come back Chef
yeah and he was like great [__]
answer
dabbed him up went back to Reno got the
call
hey when can you uh start
so I got a job at The French Laundry oh
[__] I had no idea you worked at the
[__] French Laundry bro that's that's
a [__] big [__] deal yeah see I
see I knew it too I [__] knew it so I
looked at this post video I was like
look at these [__] knife Cuts I'm
like what kind of home cook has
nightcuts that's like the first thing
remember I said I told the Tails like
yeah I was like this is odd I'm like
well of course like through culinary
school and you know all that stuff I was
like who the [__] Dyson's bell peppers
this [__] meat my bell peppers all
over the place I'm like oh my God but
yeah so I mean that's that's the after
Club 33 that's another like big um
career Milestone was like [__] finally
right like finally like something worked
out so I got the job at French Laundry
um struggled bro struggle because like
here's like fast-paced environment
um sense of urgency was high like high
pressure kitchen like you're talking
about three-star Michelin like level
status right
um
yeah I was I was doing good but just the
lifestyle of it could kicked my butt
yeah like just it all and the reason why
I haven't watched the bear yet is
because of that
um just you're talking about 14 hour
days in a high pressure like high
pressure environment it's always go go
go and making sure all your amazing
plots all your uh prep is like on point
um so like I I'm so curious about this
part of like the kitchen right because
you know from what I've seen and what
I've experienced is not at the level of
a highly misulator like like a Michelin
star restaurant like it's not what what
is like expected of you and what is the
biggest difference from that in like a
regular restaurant yeah bro well you're
expected to just put your head well just
any restaurant but at the Michelin level
you're expected to
keep your head down in his work yeah
work and work fast like get your
whatever Mease that was assigned to you
that day get it done and get it done
quick
versus say uh Applebee's right
Applebee's low but like yeah sure
there's maybe like
there's a level of urgency or whatever
but it's not as you know well the thing
is Applebee's you're working because
it's a necessity you have to work
because you got to get a paycheck right
here versus like a three minutes like
you want to be there like you risk
everything to be there so you have to
perform so the level of intensity is
just that I think that is the difference
do you think uh you working there like
leveled up your
your culinary ability the most yeah no I
think Club 33 uh had the biggest uh
influence in my culinary skill but yes
the French Laundry did have a a big
impact as well
um
but yeah just at the end of the day I
think I just got my butt kicked by not
by kitchen well yes by kitchen culture
but also just living in Napa surviving
in Napa yeah surviving in Napa on
with student loans to pay from culinary
scores
um car
uh and that was a necessity like I had
to have a car right
um and just all these other expenses I
wasn't and there was no work-life
balance right 14 14 hour days
um and I'm
getting paid ten dollars an hour yeah
and try to make that work and eventually
I I couldn't do it I was there for
almost a year and and there were many
times where I had like just meltdowns
like I couldn't hold back I don't know
why to like all the Sous chefs were like
hey what's going on like you know like
how like
like why why are you uh struggling like
towards the end of my time at the French
Laundry and all the sushi has tried to
convince me to stay but as an Asian I
feel like I didn't speak up you know
like I couldn't tell him oh like I'm
struggling with paying rent blah blah
you know like I I didn't Pride
yeah yeah maybe you know but like they
they're like oh yeah like what's going
on you know like they were trying to
find out to maybe help but I didn't I
didn't speak up
um
but yeah but also I was
the unhealthiest I've ever been mentally
physically and just uh like all around
just unhealthy like
um so I was like this is not sustainable
like and I'll also I've I was witnessing
other Cooks like uh
trying out other things to you know
sustain themselves like doing drugs or
like whatever of course you've heard
about application culture yeah a lot of
high stress environments even outside of
just um
not just the kitchen but medical
professions everything else you'd be
surprised how many people fall into
drugs just to make them feel normal yeah
um
and that is something I didn't know
until you know I became an adult yeah
and I'm seeing a lot of people in the
medical profession like who are you know
uh trauma unit like nurses ER nurses
yeah like they they do a lot of [__]
drugs just so they have something to
escape to yeah and a lot of people in
the kitchen world do a lot of drugs it's
notorious yeah in the kitchen world so I
kind of just dug deep I was like damn is
this what I want to resort to just to
you know feel normal or whatever like I
don't want to go down this path just
because I'm chasing accolades or I want
to be the best chef or a cook or
whatever
trying to work for this place right so
I thought about it and
I saw that it wasn't sustainable so I
threw in the towel and I'll tell you the
process will weed out the week
and I was that moment in my life I was
how did it make you feel to kind of
maybe in your mind fail at something
that you tried again for a third time
bro I Was Defeated it was it was
it was super rough bro because
now like when I tell people it's like oh
like fail as much as you can but what I
learned from that is fail but also
recover fast right and that the L that I
took from The French Laundry from thrown
in the towel from quitting
it
it beat me up for three years I was in I
was very depressed because it's like
it's something that I was chasing you
know for so long and something that I
finally got but I threw in the towel I
gave up and I walked away
um it was defeating so
yeah after the French Laundry went back
to Reno again
did nails for three years
three whole years this time not a couple
months three whole years and during that
time it was just like a whole like just
depressed
um identity crisis as well right because
this whole time like I'm gonna cook like
I'm gonna train to be a cook but now I'm
like rubbing old ladies feet yeah yeah
yeah yeah it was tough as a licensed
Nail Tech you know so it's like
um
yeah and during that time and to answer
your question how I got into social
media and stuff is uh during that time I
thought about you know trying other
things like photography a videography I
picked it up as a hobby to like you know
take pictures of friends family doing
portrait shots and stuff like that and
all of this was self-taught through
YouTube
um so
three years doing nails while learning
photography and videography
um and then 2019 came around
um I lost my sister
oh [__] to a car accident like she like
a fatal car accident on her way to Big
Bear
um
and that was like my wake-up call right
because the past three years I was like
in this depressive State like [__]
what's going on with my life I don't
know what to do with my life blah blah
right and then it it wasn't until I lost
a family member that was like [__] man
like life is so short you know I mean I
think that's a a theme that a lot of
kids don't understand especially like
when you're like stewing in your own
things right like the how finite life is
doesn't hit you until you're older yeah
because you think everything is for
eternity you think that your parents are
always going to be there you think that
everything here is a given and then when
it gets taken away it's like oh [__]
maybe life is a lot shorter than I
thought it was maybe there's some things
that I have to finish now before later
yeah and like it kind of sucks that for
a lot of us too not just for you like we
have to go through such trials and
tribulations to figure out what the [__]
it is that we want yeah I'm always
trying to get people to kind of get
there without that right because you
can't do it there are people who are
highly motivated without that that
trauma happening yeah and I would like
it if people could do it some people
just need that kicking their ass yeah
the the sad thing about it is is that
you don't get to choose what that moment
is though exactly it it you don't get to
see you don't get to be like oh well my
traumatizing moment was me just losing a
job yeah some people you know for you is
you having to lose a family member yeah
maybe being out on the streets like some
people just need a harder knock than
everybody else and we just don't get to
choose what that is yeah so I really do
understand what you mean by like you
know just experiencing your whatever
happens to you and then picking up and
then moving on after yeah because you
can sit around and stew in your own
filth yeah but the longer you sit in
there the longer you get comfortable
with it yeah and you're just okay with
being in this shitty [__] State yeah
it just becomes your every [__] day
yeah and then somebody has to like
either help you or grab you out but when
you kind of it's like the same concept
of being around shitty people if you're
around shitty people all the time they
become your norm and you become those
people yeah and so when you have bad
habits or when you decide to wallow in
your own filth this becomes your home
yeah you know
but yeah so I mean that that moment was
like that Lit of fire under my aspect
were you really close to your sister uh
not
during our childhood but later on in
life you know because like I think as
adults like we just kind of bonded
better
um but yeah I was
I was pretty close to her
um
and yeah when when that happened it just
made me realize like [__] like I'm over
here like just depressed all the time
thinking like you know like why did my
career work out blah blah you know but
like she didn't get to live her life
because she passed away at the age of
22. oh man yeah so it's like why the F
like why do I you know
um
uh have these feelings so I was like you
know what [__] it I'm gonna [__] go
back I'm gonna go back to culinary
I'm gonna go back to bennu oh [__] I
would make sure I get a job at venue
but this time with the French Laundry
under my belt yeah yeah yeah yeah right
so by the way guess where I was
oh French Laundry oh cool cool
so yeah so I applied for bennu uh but
this time
no stage was required
uh apply for benue but unfortunately
they were pretty filled up and they had
like International people in there like
Oh Yeah from Korea like I think mostly
Koreans were in there like from Korea
and stuff
um there was no slots for me but they're
like but we have a position at our
sister restaurant called in situ at the
SF MoMA and in situ is like a concept
where they do uh famous dishes from
chefs for around the world ooh yeah so
it's like it's in the SF Momo because
it's like they're displaying you know
these famous dishes at you know at this
restaurant
um that's very hard to do yeah right
goddamn yeah but they did it and they I
believe they had one star
oh [__] so they they did they did a
great job with that concept but it's
closed now unfortunately because I don't
think it was sustainable
um
but yeah so they said we have a position
uh we have a position at our sister
restaurant uh if you're interested you
know while you wait for something to
open up at venue I was like you know I
[__] I'll take it because here I am
been doing nails for the past three
years I'm tired of that [__] I'm I'm
ready to get back in the kitchen and you
know grind right and this was uh in 2019
early 2020. right and now I have a
little bit money from doing nails of
course uh secure my living situation I
made sure that [__] was good this time
secured a spot with other cooks too in
the building
um and then guess what David
the pandemic happened of course yeah
right and then I received an email this
was almost time for me to move like
probably like a couple like three four
days before me moving to San Fran I
received an email from the chef de
cuisine uh Brandon
a uh due to the unforeseen future uh we
can't guarantee your position here you
know because we don't know what the
climate is going to be right yeah before
shutdown right
and then boom
uh pandemic happen everybody was locked
down everybody's at home nobody's
cooking and here are like [__] what the
[__] am I gonna do you know and this is
like when Tick Tock came out and I was
like uh ticket office for the kids right
but then uh Instagram rolled out their
Instagram reels and to answer your
question of how I got into the whole
social media thing was basically during
the pandemic what was the dish that
popped you off it wasn't a dish it was
actually
um a
crispy prosciutto
how to make crispy prosciutto yeah
because people would have been like oh
that's bacon yeah prosciutto you ever
had prosciutto like no it's bacon like
no it's not it's pretty sweet like so
when people are debating it just
triggers like engagement right and that
was I think I don't know what what that
video did in terms of views but it just
popped off and back in the days or a
couple years ago like if you're talking
about like growing like big like say
growing 200 on Instagram was impossible
right yeah
um I went from a thousand eight hundred
at the startup pandemic to not start
like probably like in the middle of the
pandemic to 3 000 from one video that's
crazy I was like oh [__] the during the
pandemic a lot of people's like
Instagrams grew a lot yeah um because of
that yeah like even my Instagram it was
like stagnated at like 450 000 something
like that and then it went from 450 to
500 000. I was like the [__] I didn't do
anything because people are actually uh
consuming now before they're just
scrolling hello that's actually funny
yeah my friend was like oh you have a
half a MILF I was like do I like because
I don't really check my numbers like
that and I was like oh look at that I
was like what'd I do
I don't know if I did anything because I
post I probably one of the influencers
that posted the least
um that's pretty [__] nuts man I
think that's around the time that I
found you too no I don't think was that
like a year or so after that probably
after that because after that video I
was like damn this this is kind of nice
you know let me continue to feed the
system and and see what it does so I
kept and this was yeah it was during the
time the frio's like and it was the
early days so the algorithm was like
amazing yeah right now it's it's a such
a [__] but uh yeah it was like that too
yeah the algorithm was great and then
yeah four years down the line trash yeah
yeah so I just kept feeding the system
and I just grew like crazy within a year
like it just really came so fast but see
this is what I'm saying like
life experiences are very very important
yeah because I guarantee now now that
you've gone through all this other stuff
what you do now is it's hard but it's
nothing like it oh for damn sure bro so
when somebody looks at what you do now
they'll be like Pam this is really
difficult like how do you do this like
let me tell you what difficult was yeah
right I got scammed I was living on the
street I was here by this laundromat
[__] air yeah my sister [__] died
in my pants like this is what I mean by
perspective just to rap about what I was
talking about yeah this is what I mean
by perspective perspective matters so
[__] much no matter how many shitty
things I've went through I have never
ever said that
YouTube was hard yeah right I said like
oh I've had a hard day I never said oh
this job is so difficult I never say
that I know how what hard was I see my
parents work yeah I've seen them work
from [__] 7 A.M all the way till 8
p.m and then run to church on the
weekends they didn't have a single
[__] break seven days a week yeah up
until like seven eight years ago so I
know what [__] hard is I know what
difficult is right I know waking up and
not even knowing if you're gonna have
the lights on you know I think it's just
because they haven't been through that
or just having a hardship like that you
know so I could see like see and hearing
like your story now I understand like
how why your videos are so well put
together yeah why you have like a really
good work ethic why I see these type of
things because it's not like one day you
just woke up and had these skills
like you went through the fire yeah you
know
um and this is the important part A lot
of people see how the cookie they taste
the cookie but they don't see how it's
made yeah and I think your story is very
[__] important because now I
understand now I understand why this
[__] put a lot of work into
these Instagram reels like I mean like
looking back like looking back at it now
I think all those L's or events like at
the time man like crazy elves right but
looking back I think they were like
blessing in disguise per se because
man if like from The French Laundry
alone like I will never quit or throw in
the towel with anything again because I
know how
how bad it feels to quit
to throw in the towel so never again
will I quit like when Instagram like
gets hard or like on days where it gets
tough I'm like [__] no I'm gonna keep
going yeah and I love that too man yeah
um
the the losing part is the part that
people are scared about the most yeah
because they think that when they lose
they are branded with this title as a
failure for the rest of their lives yeah
and it's just not true yeah um a lot of
the people that I personally look up to
are people who have failed multiple
times yeah but you just don't get to
hear the stories you don't get to hear
about their struggles uh how many times
they got [__] over [__] with you
know just out on the streets just with
absolutely nothing yeah
um and you just get to see the end
result and so sometimes people who
criticize you know
um what somebody has now they don't get
to see what they did to have what they
have yeah you know so uh even for you
that's why when I look at some people
who are on YouTube right or maybe not
even YouTube maybe they just you know
post pictures on Instagram and they get
brand deals that way yeah that's fine
too but when I hear the words from their
[__] mouth and they go my life is
hard I'm like I don't think you
understand what you're saying you know
imagine what you could be doing if you
weren't doing this yeah you know so I've
you know there's somebody who wrote out
a comment in the last video too and I
understand what you're saying you go I
don't understand what David says life is
you know you know being an influencer is
easy you know like you have to do so
much stuff and like listen
I'm not saying that what I do doesn't
have like a modicum of you know
difficulty yeah I'm saying I get to do
this something I enjoy I get to talk to
somebody like David right who I I
created this world it's work yeah it's
[__] work you know I get it but I
because I'm saying it is easy work for
me it's something I can appreciate
because I know what I could be doing
yeah right I could be doing something
that I [__] hate so when I hear
people who get to choose their life
right and to go back to that topic of
what it is to be an American for me to
me being an American is the ability to
to live a life that you get to choose
yeah which is so [__] powerful so
when you have a career where you get to
wake up and choose and dictate what you
do every day and make a living and not
an okay living a good [__] living
yeah
that's what I don't want to hear I want
to hear you say today was a tough day
today I had to do a little extra work
I'm a little tired I don't ever want to
hear you say uh my life is so hard yeah
[__] I [__] I just so like I
there's so many people like like you
said perspective yeah perspective is
really [__] important man like
um I couldn't imagine just because of my
personality just being in the kitchen
somebody yelling at me yeah and not just
being like hey bro there's knives in
here I give I can't imagine that yeah
you'd be a scary [__] there's
[__] knives in here bro [__] check
your tone no and that's the thing bro
like I've witnessed some crazy stuff in
the kitchen because of that like like
you're talking like very dangerous stuff
like I I think for me it's all it's I
guess it really depends on who I respect
right because it's like Thomas Keller
yelling at me I'll eat all that [__] up
I'm like you're Thomas no like even your
peers there's purest yelling at you
peers yell at me it's like hey you ain't
nobody you have to take it because
so you have to take it it's like and the
next day they're just gonna wake up it's
like what happens like do somebody in a
[__] black math beat my ass like for
real who did that who did that I have no
idea but watch your [__] mouth it
could happen tomorrow let's go back
no I think you would do well in the
kitchen in the sense that you're
passionate about food but in terms of
like personality it's gonna be rough
amen are we talking about uh pre-therapy
David or post Theory you know even now
David dude I don't think a lot of [__]
from that's why it's hard for me in
[__] Hollywood I don't take [__] from
anybody
it's just my personality yeah but it
also really depends on the respect level
and my goal so if the goal is for me to
be a Michelin star Chef one day yeah
I'll take all that abuse exactly like I
I want I want to I want to earn my scars
yeah like I want to earn that [__] yeah
um which is basically that's what that's
what most of the people did yeah and I
think sometimes too when people look at
the the kitchen culture depending on
what you're doing they go oh you don't
need that type of stuff I think for a
certain extent yeah yeah
um but I do maybe it's just because of
the way that I grew up or maybe you grew
up I like I like that [__] though I I
kind of like the the the the trauma I
need a little trauma you know what I
mean I've been a while since my dad
yelled at me yeah put me through some
[__] I wanna I wanna feel this stuff you
know
um but when I when I look at Chefs like
you know who have such great accolades
and I see how much they sacrifice for
what they have because well now they
have the um the notoriety yeah they have
the paycheck they have all that stuff
but dude let's hear the story about
before you had that oh for damn sure and
it was [__] rough you know
um
and I just feel like hearing those
stories makes that pot a little sweeter
for me yeah because they they feel human
yeah when you hear about the person who
was like oh I was just born like this
you how can you relate to this yeah you
know but instead a majority of people
are no I I'm you I am exactly you I was
just in your spot not too long ago I
just worked my [__] ass off man and
so it makes it a little more attainable
for me yeah you know cooking is one of
those things that I you know I you know
we were before this podcast we were
talking for like two hours about food
I love food
um it's just a it's it's it's an
unspoken language that doesn't need to
be taught to anybody yeah you could sit
here break bread with somebody and you
could see somebody light up eating this
food and it's it's like a cultural
experience that they never had before
and that [__] makes me so [__] happy
yeah you know uh even owning like the
the matcha store just watching people
enjoy the matcha makes me feel really
[__] good and kind of like the way I
got to you know communicate with my mom
um even the way like I said my mom never
said sorry but you know what she does
that she [__] me up
you know it's like I get this [__]
black eye and she goes do you want some
chicken
I'm like so you stay with my mom
you want some shaking beef
no I would prefer the ass whooping not
to exist but I'll take it
no no I I feel like that's that's uh the
same thing with a lot of like Asian
families it's like um Asian parents they
don't you know tell their kids they love
them but or apologize but uh
just feed them is that you know like
whether it's fruits or like a dish or
just cook for them and yeah and you know
the the evolution of of kind of what
I've seen happen to Asians but we were
talking about Jonathan Gold yeah uh rest
in peace one of my favorite food critics
of all time
um I think Asian food is really getting
the respect that it deserves right now
now yeah because
I want to say people just kind of looked
at Asian food as oh that's I might be
being a little hyperbolic to a lot of
people but you know if you're a lot
younger but it was like oh that's dirty
food yeah a lot of people had those type
of sentiments about Asian food yeah even
though these [__] would eat hot
dogs like the [__] are you talking about
dude the [__] audacity you know what
I mean yeah you just had [__]
Tostitos pizza rolls which are
fired
I told myself not to judge hey let me
tell you something I love toast I love
listen grow a nugget I like food that I
was not allowed to have as a kid
struggle food struggle food bro like I
remember just this is so stupid but
because I wouldn't have it so I wanted
it yeah like the ham and cheese [__]
white bread [__] sandwich I'm like oh
my God damn I want to hey for some
memory this is
for some reason I don't know what it is
no like beach days and like picnics oh
my God exactly and so you know we grew
up in a time where sometimes our food
was looked down upon yeah so when
somebody I think sometimes this concept
gets a little convoluted where they go
where you'll heal so here's somebody
who'll make a hubbub about like somebody
misrepresenting their food and
um sometimes it's warranted sometimes
it's not so I think sometimes people
[__] on other chefs just because it's
the hot thing to do yeah um but there
are times where if your culture is
misrepresented it's going to feel a
certain way because there was a time
where if I brought the food that I
enjoyed it was called disgusting yeah so
it hits different there's like there's
things that we have to work through that
so
um when I when I was a kid I never
really understood it because I was just
always kind of just didn't give too many
[__] about things so I remember I
brought this kimchi fried rice to school
and then my dad looked at me and he goes
don't bring that to school and I said
why he's like because they're gonna say
it smells but I just I just wanted to
eat it yeah I didn't really care
um but damn did you learn I know and
they made fun of me for it right but me
being a fat boy I'm like this is good
yeah
I guess you know I'm just eating it but
my dad worried for me it would work for
me that my food would smell because I
remember being in my parents store my
parents would be eating Korean food and
the customers would be like oh what the
[__] the [__] things in here yeah and
but look at how things are now yeah now
it's like oh what is that let's go
Korean barbecue yeah everybody wants
kimchi left them right you know yeah and
I'm not saying [__] you I'm saying I
like it I appreciate it a lot that we
finally gotten to this point yeah where
people are starting to appreciate the
amount of work it takes to create the
food that you used to call Dirty yeah it
is hard yeah to make this food
um so when I hear you know maybe that's
why when the you know at whatever your
job at Disney they were like oh you just
put that bottle salsa you know what it
takes to make [__] fish sauce I mean
he was right yeah I don't give a [__]
that's one of the best condiments ever
you could put that on just rice and eggs
and you're set yeah legit one of my
favorite there are like mother sauces in
every culture right yeah fish sauce is a
freaking mother that is a mother sauce
right and I think you know when you when
I first started really reading like
culinary books for fun you know you
always go to like you know French
Culinary first right yeah they always
had their mother sausage right
but then I find out the sauces that I
enjoy are actually very Asian based yeah
because ours is a lot lighter and a lot
more acidic yeah you know which is what
I prefer that's why I like a lot of Thai
sauces Vietnamese sauces Citrus is very
prevalented a lot of fresh herbs so
that's what I kind of gravitate towards
got some Meyer lemons in the bag oh you
know
what I have so this is out in uh K-Town
and it's an Argentinian spot but it's
owned by a Korean family my buddy Eddie
so he cooks Argentinian food the way
Argentinian Koreans cook food wow
because there's a huge Korean Community
really I didn't know that so when people
yeah a huge Korean population of
Argentina and so when people eat the
food they're like oh this isn't real
Argentinian food and he goes He defends
it adamantly he goes I lived in
Argentina this is Argentinian foreign
but it takes somebody to really [__]
with their culture just to stand their
ground and say oh for sure this is my
culture yeah and this is what I [__]
so his chimichurri is less olive oil
based more vinegar based because it
works with the Korean powder we like
bright acidic flavors yeah right
especially when it comes to fatty Meats
like beef ribs yeah he uses USDA prime
just balance well exactly this makes
sense so for me I prefer the more heavy
on the shallots more on the vinegar side
of his chimichurri compared to the ones
that I've had like at Argentine
restaurants yeah because I like the way
that it cuts the fat yeah you know but
who's to say whose is right or wrong
yeah like that's his experience you know
I mean yes to a certain point because
like at the end of the day it's like
back to what we were discussing earlier
like is it good yeah you know I mean
that's what I wanted I I get where the
you know argentinians you know 100 but
well I'm talking about non-argentinians
that's even worse yeah that's a whole
different story you're telling this guy
who who lived in Argentina
how he should have his food yeah you
know what I mean yeah
um
and I think that's the hard part about
Yelp culture too everybody is a food
critic everybody's a food critic
everybody likes to bash somebody's stuff
before they even think about the
repercussions right it's like think
about what you do to this business
unless they really really [__]
deserve it yeah but if it's like you
went in and you know you didn't think
the food was that good do you have to
give it a one star like that person has
a family to feed that person has a
living to make yeah
um
and I think like when people work in the
kitchen they'll figure it out or when
they start cooking for themselves and
they know that like oh this like I could
make a better fub rather could you could
you really
listen I've tried
I [__] that up twice and I'm never
making it again no I think I with
majority of the diners or just consumers
um I would say is like they see the
product and they don't see the work that
goes into the product you know like and
not even the work like the labor the
ordering
um and just people who consume content
as well like they see you know your
piece or whatever they don't see the
work that goes on behind the scene to
get to that 30 second clip you know but
they're quick to judge and I think
that's what
and it's sad yeah yeah I wish people
would just kind of sometimes you know
we're talking about first things yeah
have some perspective and then really
just try cooking yeah try try really
cooking at home first
um and operating on camera
and being your own sound guy yeah try it
out it's it's it'll it'll help you
appreciate food better too yeah right
for sure it'll help you like understand
like okay I like this because of these
reasons not just you know meh and then
you [__] on it right yeah because it's
like when I first started I watched MMA
my whole life right that I only started
like seriously taking kickboxing maybe
four years ago no three years ago and
now I appreciate the sport more I see
things more now yeah I can understand it
better and I enjoy it more and I think
that's what happens with food when I
started to read more books and I started
trying to cook it and by but I'm just
I'm just a home cook but now that when I
go to restaurants I I see the effort and
I used to be that yelper but I never
yelped but in my mind I'd be like oh
this restaurant just opens up and they
don't give me Perfection yeah and I go
oh this place sucks now I go
I could see the potential let me come
back in about a month when they fix when
they fine-tune things how it should be
yeah with everybody and the [__]
restaurant turned out to be hella good
yeah I was like oh okay yeah I mean well
with new restaurants like they're still
working out their Kinks and whatnot so
it's like it's yeah yeah and I still I
think
um with a lot of these restaurants too
people just kind of just sacrifice them
so fast give them an opportunity a
chance some places you might not like
that's fine yeah but I definitely have a
a different perspective when I try try
food now there's places too like for
example I went to this uh barbecue spot
um in town
yeah not that great I'll take you to
dude
Adam Perry Lang oh I was did you go I
did not I was gonna ask if he's still
operating yeah so he's out in Torrance
now at the at a strand Brew at the
Strand Brewery in Torrance everybody go
check it out Saturdays and Sundays
that's the homie he's a good friend of
mine I'll introduce you to him after a
bun sale okay we're gonna go there we're
still homies after month sale then we'll
go [__] I you know what you're
gonna eat those [__] words bro either
I'm gonna tell the person that you hated
it I was like he hates it he [__]
hates it after my second try of course
I'm not gonna knock him on the first try
yeah man I gotta introduce you to Adam
man super sounds like he's super
passionate about bro is he like a
certified Pit Master Certified Pit
Master man like this man is like Stripes
like three stripes he's like he's the
God so like I bet yeah his stuff looked
great so his his smoker that he has is
the original smokers a smoker uh from
Franklin
shut up yeah so that's how close he is
to everybody wow so
um legit the best barbecue that you
could have on the west coast uh how many
days a week Saturday and Sunday okay so
only on the weekend yeah so he does the
pop-up at the brewery so we can get
beers and then we could his beef ribs
bro I'm telling you right now it's
otherworldly David don't don't tell me
what a good time it's [__] other
words this man has given me avocados
it's only the first day I chill like I
haven't I haven't been there in like two
months just because I've been you know
opening the store in Hawaii yeah but I
was going there every week like I was
just gonna ask you if he's opening or
that's where I was gonna like hey uh APL
you know yeah so Adam Perry Lang man
like when I I love talking to him
because
he went through the same tropes uh which
I have to get him on this podcast too he
uh went through the same tropes of
opening up his fine dining restaurant
yeah APL you know and I think that he
enjoyed it and what he kind of alluded
to to me was that he just needed to get
back to what made him passionate about
food yeah which was barbecue yeah and he
went back to it and he is hap I've never
seen him so happy yeah and he's and you
know what the proof is in the pudding
people are coming from all over the city
to eat his food yeah that's how good it
is that's how much hours he puts into
his [__] crap yeah everything is
[__] fine-tuned man and when
something isn't good enough for him it
eats him up oh for damn sure you know I
bet when I watch him cook it makes me
want to do better I'm not a chef I want
to do better in my own stuff yeah it is
the amount like you're inspired by the
Um passion that he's putting into his
class 100 he inspires me all the [__]
time and I gotta the next time I go
you're gonna come with and we're going
to get Bun sale first I'm going to go
after oh we'll see
if you don't like that that goes back to
what I was saying earlier to you in the
car is like it's you know um
chefs they go through all this you know
hardship or to pursue fine dining right
but it turns out that you know that's
they're doing that for their ego but at
the end of the day it's not what makes
them happier what
um what got them started cooking in the
first place you know like with a with
Adam is like now he Com or he shifted to
barbecue and with a couple you told me
about they shifted to uh their other
concept you know so it's not always fine
dining you know yeah and it's it's that
fine dining world is a tough World bro
yeah like I said watching the bear and
then having the chef buddy say that's
that's my that was my life yeah
and I understand when you told me you
broke down and cried I'm like I would
have too bro I fought like
imagine like being a grown man in front
of another girl man hold like fighting
back tears bro like I I didn't want to
cry but like just my body just like you
know just I would have just started
chopping onions in front of them
it sounds like you're bawling though
yeah
these onions are they intense it is like
damn well you get these shits they're
from France
yeah but man I I really do I think you
are probably I say in terms of like
Instagram like food content creators
you're my favorite one thank you so much
and I'm not just saying that because
you're here too right because I've you
know I know a lot of people who are in
food but your videos are tried and true
because I know off jump the moment you
put out a recipe I'm gonna it's going to
be good yeah and if I serve it to my
friends yeah they'll be like oh how did
you learn how to do that I'm like I did
it myself
yeah but I I know that if I make your
food for somebody else yeah they're
gonna enjoy it because I know it's going
to be good which a lot of people just
don't take that time into their stuff
and it you know like I said I'm not
hating but it just it [__] just
try you know like I know that you have
to create content but you could also
create great content too you don't
always just have to put out a video
every day and then have it just be have
it suck yeah because honestly too your
reputation does matter and people learn
from you like you're a source of
knowledge now and that is why I R D
um no but for the record I with you
saying that I just want to say thank you
so much because when you first three
posts my video and you
um or like you may contact in the DMs I
think during that time uh I was just
growing growing like crazy and it got
really overwhelming you know like brand
deals coming in I was still by myself
um handling all emails and on the
content side so things got really really
stressful to a point where like [__] bro
like
what do I do you know like and I was
getting burnt like from all that right
and then you came at a time where
where all that was going on and your
words I think
in the DMG says something along the
lines of like don't stop making these
videos like these are [__] good yeah
you know and for me I was like damn like
one of the OG's like you know hit me up
and gave me that little bit of
encouragement so that meant a lot to me
and it just lifted me out of that
difficult small time oh man I'm glad I
could do that because for the record I
just want to say thank you oh man dude
like I I I just want people who you're
not doing what I do but yeah I want
people that kind of represent
just really good things to survive and I
think sometimes with really dedicated
focus and kind people they get
eaten up a lot because you care about
your craft more than other people yeah
and sometimes when that's not either
reciprocated you feel like you're doing
what am I doing this for yeah and so I
always try to post people and kind of
like even if I don't put it in a post
I'm always telling other people hey you
got to check out this content created
out because I want people like you to
not only just survive but I want you to
thrive because what you do will
inadvertently
kind of motivate the Next Generation in
the way that I want it to happen yeah I
don't like you don't create fast quick
content yeah you do you know fast
content but it's very precise and on top
of that is passionate and it's in the
right direction you know and I think
like the knowledge base that you give to
a crowd is something that you offer
something very unique that other people
don't care to do because it's too much
work yeah and so I I appreciate that and
it's a world where people just won't do
that yeah and so when I talk about you I
brought my friend
um
sushan here he's a rapper yeah and I see
it and sometimes
it goes unrecognized yeah and I just if
I'm somebody who wants to because I I
don't know how long I'm going to be on
the space not because I can't be on it
yeah I've just done this for so long and
obviously I'm doing a lot of other
things yeah so if I am going to leave
this space in the next three or four
years I hope that the people that I can
motivate or push are people like you
because you'll you'll take over my spot
or and most multiple people will and
they have yeah so it's just it's just
really it's weird because if you do well
it makes me feel good and it makes me do
well so it just works both ways yeah so
your success helps me to be successful
as well yeah so I just always want to
not so much help but just know that look
there are people out here who are
watching what you're doing and they
appreciate you the way that you should
be appreciated you know
yeah I was I was super thankful for that
because it just I don't know like you
you might have thought that maybe it
wouldn't meant a lot because it was just
like a you know a comment they made but
for me it was like [__] like you know it
my work is recognized by one of the ogs
and just recently too like something
again like that happened with another
big name that like okay like here we go
you know after my move back to Orange
County and I was like just in this head
weird headspace and then that person
slid in my DM like keep going man like
I'm rooting for you I was like [__] all
right cool like somebody from at at his
level like it's was it a chef no
uh I I won't say his name but it rhymes
with Jerry B
oh let's go baby no so I'm like okay
like like the influence or like the
social media guys is like recognizing
the work so it's like now I just gotta
you know double down like [__] that
man reaches out to everybody you know
yeah so it's it's it meant a lot it
should mean a lot that's [__] it
means a lot to me and I don't it's not
even to me you know you are David
that's pretty [__] amazing man and I
gotta tell you dude those are the those
are those big victories right yeah
because
our fan base Keeps Us Alive which you
know we're all so appreciative about
yeah but it's also great to know that
people who are our peers in this space
also respect what we do as well
um
I mean I'm somebody who typically you
know I say like I don't care but I do
care to which I just don't let things
eat me up yeah
but like for example if Dave Chappelle
came up to me goes [__] you're
the most unfunniest person I've ever met
in my life I'm like okay I'm going to
die now yeah so that would hurt me a lot
so when somebody who is in our space
appreciates what we do it also feels
really good yeah so it kind of helps us
to push forward man
um I'm really glad you got to tell your
stories [__] nuts bro that's actually
a lot crazier than I thought it was
going to be oh for real yeah I thought
we were just going to talk food today
you know like I didn't think we were
gonna spill it all but no it's good dude
like I I need stories like this too yeah
because you know for me I'm somebody
who's very internal I keep to myself a
lot in terms of like struggles that I go
through I don't talk a lot about my
struggles because I feel like I reach
out to my wife and I have a good Circle
to help me out yeah
um but like I said perspective is
[__] everything to me and like
hearing your story is great now it's
like for me I feel hey I could
I can go through my struggles when
things go bad yeah perspective
everything man well hey where can they
find you
um on all platforms at DVD
Gwen Nguyen yep so check out his recipes
uh I religiously follows his follow his
Instagram looking for new recipes all
the time whatever you make from him just
to know that it's going to be a banger
if you're a virgin out there you're
gonna get some [__] you're gonna get
that etouffee [__] that was funny
there's dudes in my DMs literally bro
thank you so much
thank you I got my dick sucked tonight
and they I use a little bit too much
cayenne pepper and it burned a little
bit but fantastic but it's funny we joke
like we joke about it but it it's
actually true like
hey bro it works out dude some people
gotta cook their way into some vagina I
had a gig on my way I had to make
shaking beef
she [__] lacked those balls baby
let's go
um genius praying every Sundays at 12
p.m hope you guys enjoyed that pause
podcast uh leave comments if you're
watching this on the video side uh let
me know who you want me to interview on
here if I [__] with them I will if not
then you probably won't see them but
we'll see you all next time peace